plein merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
de l'éducation nationale madame la
ministre vous n'avez pas été à la
hauteur dimanche sur canal+ à l'émission
le supplément cette émission vous les
montrer à travers une ong musulmane un
autre visage de l'islam
à quoi avons nous assisté nous avons vu
un homme qui refuse de saluer une
ministre de la république parce que
c'est une femme
je ne serre pas la main aux femmes
affirme sur le plateau idriss 6 à midi
nous avons vu un responsable associative
soi disant humanitaires qui refuse de
condamner une organisation terroriste en
l'occurrence l'état islamique
nous avons vu une ministre de la
république passive qui réagit à minima
devant des propos purement scandaleux
madame le député que je suis fait en ce
moment l'objet d'une plainte de la part
de sos racisme parce qu'en tant que
maire en septembre dernier j'ai attiré
l'attention de l'opinion sur le risque
d'infiltration de terroristes islamistes
parmi les réfugiés alors qu'il a été
démontré depuis le 13 novembre que c'est
une réalité
madame en ce moment un procureur de la
république me poursuit pour soi-disant
provocation à la discrimination raciale
ou religieuse
certains incitent à la haine sur un
plateau de télé en votre présence sans
que vous ne réagisse y est pendant que
moi
préférant protéger mes compatriotes et
des bombes demandant à l'état des
garanties sur les migrants qui déferle
sur notre pays et qu'on me propose
d'accueillir dans ma ville je dois
accepter d'être montré du doigt
poursuivi par la justice de mon pays
madame vous avez été ministre des droits
des femmes vous allez porter en 2013 la
loi sur l'égalité entre les hommes et
les femmes
vous êtes aujourd'hui ministre
l'éducation nationale et vous n'avez pas
eu le courage de vous lever de donner
tout simplement l'exemple
madame par votre silence vous avez
laissé faire par votre complaisance vous
n'avez pas été à la hauteur
la parole est à madame najat
vallaud-belkacem ministre de l'éducation
nationale de l'enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
nicolas le combat contre le terrorisme
et la radicalisation nécessite l'unité
nationale et se passe des polémiques
artificielles de quoi parlons nous d'une
émission de télévision qui ce week-end a
reçu un président d'association venu
défendre l'un des siens ont retenu en
captivité au bangladesh
et qui c'est vrai a tenus sur le plateau
des propos qui ont abasourdi tout le
monde je les ai condamné je les ai
condamné bien évidemment et j'ai refusé
de servir la soupe à ce monsieur en lui
offrant une tribune supplémentaire
monsieur le député ma règle est simple
on ne débat pas contre les ennemis de la
république on le combat on les combat
est mon combat est totale il exclu tout
dialogue artificielle et toute une
semaine
mon action se situe au sein de mon
ministère où tout est entrepris pour
démonétisé ses discours et pour défendre
la laïcité c'est le sens de tout ce qui
a été mis en oeuvre pour former les
enseignants pour développer l'éducation
civique et morale pour faire en sorte
que l'on rétablisse des règles claires
sur la laïcité monsieur le député
faut-il vous rappeler que tout ce
travail n'a pas été mis en oeuvre par
votre majorité dans le passé c'est
pourquoi je n'accepte aucune leçon
d'anti-islamisme de la part de ceux qui
n'ont pas conduit ce travail donc je
redis très calmement devant vous je
condamne évidemment les propos qui ont
été tenus par ce président d'association
sur ce plateau
je regrette qu'on lire offert une
tribune une fois encore l'école est
totalement engagée pour transmettre les
valeurs que nous sommes en train de
défendre car nous n'avons qu'un ennemi
de part et d'autre de cette assemblée
je vous invite à ne pas abîmer ce
travail par des polémiques dérisoires
merci madame la ministre d'abord l'état
monsieur jean-jacques